area 51 was built around a dry lake bed
known as groom lake it offered obvious
advantages
well we needed a good place to land that
we could land any direction depending on
where the wind came from and the round
lake
served that purpose it was also
protected
the mountain range around it so it
wasn't very visible
smooth as glass just
unbelievable i could take that staff car
out there
as fast as he'd go and it wouldn't even
make a bump
we had a bunch of trailers
for us to live in
and we had a all-purpose building where
you eat
didn't have tv didn't even have a radio
paradise ranch was the first name
that was given to the establishment they
thought it would soften the blow of
the austerity it was attempt to perhaps
convince people it wasn't
quite as bad as it looked
area 51 was created for one top secret
project
called aquatone
in 1955 men from the cia
the air force and a secret division of
lockheed
came to paradise ranch to begin work
all they would tell us was we had to go
for a pressure suit
so we knew it was going to be high
altitude stuff
your blood boils above 50 000
without having pressurization so if you
were to
lose pressurization just your engine
calm count you're above 50
that suit saves you when pilots fly
higher
than man has ever flown equipment
changes are necessary
in this declassified footage ray gowdy
prepares for a flight
inside area 51.
the men looked like nothing seen on
earth and rumors about what was going on
inside area 51 started to swirl
it was so secret i didn't know what it
was until i got
there and
wondered what i got myself into
the men were testing one of the most
important tools of the cold war
the u2 spy plane
there was no trainer there's no
two-seater
there was no simulator
the u2 was equipped with high-resolution
cameras
designed to fly at 70 000 feet and take
photographs from the edge of the
stratosphere
as the cold war arms race with the
soviet union intensified
the u2 was america's best hope for
tracking their rivals growing nuclear
arsenal
and it put enormous demands on pilots
who had to breathe pure oxygen to
survive at such heights
pilots find the confines of the helmet
and face plate conducive to
claustrophobia
a number of pilots have been dropped
from the program because of this single
factor
[Music]
the government's cover story for the u2
was that it was being used
for weather research if not conventional
aircraft then
what did they see the u2 cruised at
three times the height of regular
airliners
and would sometimes be glimpsed by
civilians i believe i saw the sun
glinting off of windows or observation
portholes in the mid-1950s
while both the cold war and america's
interest in ufos were at their peak
i think it was from outer space but
friendly
the silver-colored plane sometimes
created confusion
it was pure aluminum and we said
hey we look like a bright star up there
pilots were told to deny everything even
to aircraft controllers there are
stories about
seeing something flying way above they
may have
called it in but they'll still get
nothing other than
evasive stuff if you get up along the
canadian border
the ground controller questioned my
altitude
actually he was pretty accurate and i
says no you got to recalibrate your
weapon
that's not the altitude we're at
by 1957 unacknowledged u2 flights
were the source of half of all reported
ufo sightings
but they were nothing compared to what
would come
[Music]
you